our top story tonight a source with the  associated press is reporting that  president trump has signed a government  funding bill  which includes 900 billion dollars in  pandemic relief  thank you so much for joining us tonight  at six o'clock i'm sasha loftis  the president is in florida for  christmas holiday but on thursday the  legislation was sent to him from  washington  in hopes that he would sign it quickly  in a statement the president  says he signed it to restore  unemployment benefits stop evictions and  provide  rental assistance however he says he  still wants changes to the measure  including two thousand dollar stimulus  checks rather than six hundred  the president says that starts with a  vote on the house  or in the house rather on monday